there's something mythological about
confronting yeah right you know I've
never seen myself as particularly
talented where I excel is I'm willing to
die in the process of acquiring skill I
don't mind being scared but I'm still
gonna do it
wanna soar get a mentor
what's up belief nation is heaven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn
from one of the best Will Smith and five
of his most life-changing pieces of
advice mentor me we'll also if you want
to know what Will Smith and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my to 54 confident series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
I was excited about taking a shot the
fact that it was so strange you know as
an artist
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one take that shot we not just bungee
jump in by the helicopter we're gonna do
it at the grant camp and when I was up
there and and I jumped I realized you
know it's fun and it's exciting and
there's something mythological about
confronting death right because as much
as we're laughing in these buses we're
having fun it really is the emotional
confront with death you know and I'm 50
years old now
and I'm sort of having the realization
that you you have to be able to go
[Music]
you have to be able to take that shot at
the thing that you dream you have to be
able to take that shot at that that love
that you want but that life that you
want to build and it's like you know
when I was up there and the guys said to
me the only way you can get hurt is if
you don't get away from the chapel right
and he said in that moment he said we're
gonna let the courts go on these courts
weigh 200 pounds right so when we let
him go they're gone the hesitation is
the thing that really messes up the
chance at having your dreams right get
out of the middle
push it off is pure frickin terror is
the moment of falling with you guys so
it's really that you can do just like
life there's nothing to hold on to and
we're all trying to hold on to something
you're trying to hold on to an idea or
you're trying to hold on to a person and
there's nothing to hold on to and we
gotta just get comfortable
falling knowing there's nothing to hit
right you know and that's the idea it's
like life is dangerous and the only way
to really enjoy it is jump and be free
rule number two do not be outworked I
told the famous survive you kind of
backed into acting Fresh Prince of
bel-air yeah and the next thing you know
you start making these movies and I
forget that bad boys actually came
before Independence Day right yeah yeah
tennis day just was like one of the
biggest of all time like what was that
transition like for you yeah you know
actor and like the biggest actor in the
game no it was um that was like the
first real goal like that in terms of
setting goals I was like I want to be
the biggest movie star in the world
right and every up until that point
everything was like it was fun and it
was happening and we were creating in
Jeff's mom's basement and it was
successful but that was like when I
moved into acting that was the first
time I started applying skill to my my
talents right and you know I always look
I look at skill and talent separately
like Pete you're born with talent you
know it's like there's certain things
that you just do naturally you were
gifted with a talent and you have it but
skill is acquired through discipline and
you know I've never seen myself as
particularly talented where I excel is
I'm willing to die in the process of
acquiring skill like is you
when I put my obsessive mind or sign the
trend I'm just yeah exactly it's not
working yes is a ridiculous is sickening
working sickening work ethic exactly
it's like you know so for me to be a
movie star was the first thing that I
ever really wanted like that and set my
he was like all of them I was like I was
like you know because I went out when I
looked I always felt like there weren't
a lot of people I saw do things that I
felt like I couldn't do right when I
when I look at people and I see things I
don't I don't feel like I can't but
whether or not I will is something
different but I don't ever feel like I
can rule number three improve yourself
the concept of improving lives runs
through the center of everything I do
and then I realize that the the way to
improve lives is to continually improve
yourself right so with that every every
morning when I when I get out of the bed
you know I I haven't fixed everything in
the world yet so there's always
something to do and in this film I read
an interesting quote the Siddhartha
Gautama the Buddha he said that good
people have to get out of the bed every
day and try to empty the ocean with a
ladle right and I thought that was you
know I knew that was profound and I
paused for a second and I said all right
what the hell is a ladle right right so
there you know I just I touched it on my
iPad is ladle oh it's like a big spoon
okay so try to empty the ocean with a
soup spoon you know as the the mentality
of how you you wake up every day to try
to do good in the world so for me I'm
really driven by continually trying to
elevate my elevate my mind and elevate
my spirit and care for my body and
to be able to love as many people as
effectively as as possible with this
mystery of life that I've been given
rule number four don't let fear stop you
[Music]
my parents drove us cross-country - we
were going to California for a family
reunion so we drove to the Grand Canyon
and we got there and I like I remember
having a deeply meaningful experience of
how beautiful it was but I was terrified
to walk up to the edge and all my
brothers and sisters and my whole family
walked up to the edge and I stayed back
just scared to to take in beauty if
you're scared you're not going to take
the chances that you need to take - to
realize your dreams and that was the
thing for me I don't mind being scared
but I'm still gonna do it and rule
number five the last one before a very
special bonus clip is develop
self-discipline so I do scream to me the
other night a will I want to be active
man I will be active just like you you
know usually people say stuff to me like
that I'm like yeah man you know you do
is give them an encouraging word but I
was just sitting here thinking and it
dawned on me 99% of people that say
stuff like that are not willing to do
what it takes to make their dreams come
true the Marines have a saying everybody
wants to go to heaven but nobody wants
to die and that's just real at the
center of bringing any dream into
fruition is self-discipline you know
something something as simple as food
and eating it is not about your body as
much as it is about your mind it's
getting command of your mind to be able
to choose actions that are in your own
best interest every day we are choosing
that's not in our own best interest
right so if the world is attacking you
in the world
wants to fight you in the world's trying
to hold you down so you're gonna kick
yourself in the balls so you will stop
yourself from getting what you dream
self-discipline is the center of all
material success you cannot win the war
against the world if you can't win the
war against your own mind
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from will on how to focus that I think
you're gonna really enjoy but before
that it's time for the three-point
landing questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your life or your
business so answer these three questions
and if you're feeling bold leave the
replies in the comments below here we go
question number one what is the
self-discipline that you need to start
developing number two what fear will you
no longer let stop you and number three
what are you going to improve yourself
on today
I realized that when you to have the
level of success that I want to have
it's difficult to spread it out and do
multiple things you know it's in order
to to be world-class and I've made a
decision I want to be world-class and it
just it takes such a desperate obsessive
focus to to excel on assert honor on the
level that I want to make movies you
know I was a Star Wars when I was young
i sat in the movie theater and watched
Star Wars and I just couldn't believe
that that movie made me feel like that
just floored and just stunned by the
creativity and just I'm realizing that
in order to move people in that way in
order to touch people in that way you've
really got to focus with all of your
fiber and all your heart and all your
creativity raise your standard Apple at
the core its core value is that that
people need passion and not one drop of
my self-worth depends on your it's
suppose to mean
if you want to know how Will Smith
develops his insane work ethic check out
the video right there next to me I think
you're gonna enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there you know
there was um excuse me there was a
moment when I was about nine years old